so there's a part in the middle of the
movie where the screen goes blank and
it's like oh no the jungler's loose in
the theater
why do you say that all creatives have a
creature living inside of them did i say
that yeah it sounds like something i
would say you said it was like this
creature that was always like oh we
could do that oh and i can make that and
it's it can be a blessing and a curse
and and the curse is it won't leave you
alone because you
you're always thinking of these new
ideas and how you want to like make
something yeah
i uh i really love this movie the
tingler
that is a william castle film starring
vincent price where vincent price is a
scientist that discovers that fear is a
creature that lives on your spinal cord
and the creature gets bigger and bigger
it feeds off your fear and the only way
to shrink the creature back down is by
screaming
and the whole movie is about
this they get a mute girl who can't
scream and they scare her to force this
creature to break out and then the
creature gets loose so they can try to
experiment with the creature
but i always really enjoyed that premise
because i feel that's the same way with
creativity you have a monster living
inside you
that is so desperate to do things
creatively and this goes back to passion
versus obsession too because it's like
you go to bed sometimes like i have an
idea oh my gosh this is a great idea i
gotta write this down i gotta figure out
a way to do this i gotta pitch it to
somebody i gotta see about it
it's like a madness
that i feel like kind of lives inside
and everyone has a bit of a
multiple personalities right
so you have this creature that lives
inside of you that's just whispering
these great ideas in your ear you're
like oh yeah that is a good idea oh i
could totally do that oh i could change
this or blah blah and so
i i like the whole idea that you have a
friend that's with you you know
um
so it's just yeah so your creativity is
this creature that lives inside of you
that uh that is constantly forcing you
to get excited about things and then
trying to figure out how to accomplish
them but it's it's it is a bit of
madness it does drive you crazy
sometimes because
not everyone can just go out and make
whatever they want at all times not not
decently and there's certain projects
that you want to wait until you can do
them correctly or hopefully do them
correctly or get the right kind of
budget you need or the right team
and so
i think that every i mean every creative
is a little bit mad
of course
but it's almost as if it's coming from
somewhere else
it's not really you
i mean i feel like everyone
talks to themselves
everyone has conversations in their head
oh yeah absolutely who are you talking
to it's just you there's no one else in
there right or is there someone else in
there
so i always loved that movie identity
where they have the guy who's
kind of a spoiler i guess but has all
the different personalities that persona
that turn into people and it's all the
different elements of his personality
all these different people and they're
all different but
you know everyone works better in groups
right we we like to work in groups we
like to work in teams it makes things
easier so the idea that you have me
myself and i
your your trinity inside of you that's
all working together to to make things
happen i think is a comforting feeling
to where
the world isn't always 100 on your
shoulders even though it seems like it
because you have you yourself and i to
to help out you know
and your little creative monster that
lives that lives in your spinal cord it
helps it helps lift that weight because
being in an entertainment you know we
have a very big responsibility
and you look at things like the great
depression you look at the history of
movies in the great depression all
movies turned to comedy because people
desperately needed a way to escape how
tragic reality was and we've had that
same thing happen this past year with
covet people are trapped at home well
netflix numbers are skyrocketing because
they're stuck at home they need that
escape they need entertainment to
survive
and i really think that it's it's
important you know what we do it's not
just for fun and giggles and it seems
like it to some people
but
it is really important because a lot of
people's livelihood
it this this helps them it's their
escape from reality it helps keep them
sane so their monsters don't get loose
on them
and um
[Music]
and i'm really proud to be a part of all
that especially when you can provide
someone entertainment with your with
your work i mean that's an amazing
amazing feeling
what year did that movie come out with
vincent price oh gosh
60s okay i'm not sure the exact year
and what's the title of it again it's
called the tingler the tingler that's
right you said that it was it was a
william castle movie and they put
buzzers all around the theater so
there's a part in the middle of the
movie where the screen goes blank and
it's like oh no the jungler's loose in
the theater and just starts shocking
people people are screaming and jumping
up and running around and yeah that's a
good one
so the only negative to having this
creature and this metaphorical creature
inside of you is that it's frustrating
because you can't get all of the
projects you want done
well it's hungry you know it's a hungry
creature and if it's not fed
it gets angry and
i ended up starting in video and then a
few years later i ended up getting into
photography because i was like oh
photography is exactly like filmmaking
only it's one frame instead of 24 frames
a second
so i only have to make one picture and i
have a lot more control and it's a lot
cheaper and i only need one model or a
couple models and i can do whatever i
want and then i learned photoshop and
i'm like now i can really make whatever
i want composite people into crazy
locations
because i need that creative outlet as
creatives like we have to feed the beast
so
you you want that and that creature is
hungry and so you got to figure out ways
to do it and
people i think that our creatives will
find that way either through writing or
art or filmmaking
or basket weaving or whatever is on
their etsy site you know you can find a
creative outlet but you kind of feel
like you have to do it because
of this starving monster inside of you
that needs to be fed
did you always honor that creature i
mean were there
when you were growing up did you have
other plans for
a quote-unquote career did were there
other classes you were taking
i never had a plan b
like not really i really
knew very strongly what i wanted to do
and thought that it would be possible
i think especially the late 90s like
when i was in high school when dvds
first came out they had these things
called special features which you never
got on vhs tapes very rarely would you
get like a second vhs tape that had like
behind the scenes the only time you ever
get to see behind the scenes is on like
a
like an entertainment news that would
play for half an hour a night you know
before the sitcoms came on or an hbo
special or something so you never really
got to experience what it was like
behind the camera so i remember starting
to see these special features and being
like oh man look at how they make these
movies like i didn't even think about it
as a kid i just thought these movies
just came out of nowhere they just poof
existed but then you see the whole
processes and making that magic happen
and being a child and having so many
movies affect you as a kid and
you know i i grew up as a horror kid i
mean i love slasher movies and some
people watch star wars i didn't watch
star wars i was an adult like i watched
freddie and jason and like this was
where i like to escape to
and horror is a really is a really
important thing to me too the horror
genre because
a lot of people look at as horror as
like oh it's exploitive it's splatter
it's gross like why do you want to focus
on death like horror doesn't focus on
death horror focuses on life
you know you as a viewer survive
no matter what the movie there's people
that don't survive
and it really lights a fire under you
hopefully to be like man i could have
been that guy that just took a machete
to the head but i didn't i lived i need
to take advantage of this there's such
an inspiring me as a kid i was so
inspired because it's like oh look i
lived no i need to take advantage of
this life while i have it before some
crazy hockey mask killer shows up in the
middle of the night and granted it's fun
or that a lot of them are fun but
i always felt like that it's an
adrenaline rush it's like a roller
coaster and then at the end but you
survive no matter what and that's an
exciting thing and i like bringing up
the audiences for sure